le rapport de la cob oui il y a eu délit
d'initié mais les coupables ne sont pas
identifiés un nom tout de même souligner
celui de max théret invité du journal
pierre bérégovoy ministre de l'économie
et des finances hans est il plus que la
cob qui lui dira hiver exceptionnel
sécheresse paradoxal et une surprise en
plus la pollution exemple l'italie et
plus particulièrement milan les espions
de la fusée ariane
ils obtiennent un non lieu il n'avait
jamais espionné pour l'union soviétique
la mort d'un prince alphonse de bourbon
s'est fait en descente dans un accident
de ski problèmes de dépendances
bonsoir le voici enfin le rapport de la
cob sur la sphère pesci mais c'est cela
un petit document de 47 pages seulement
que la commission des opérations de
bourse a rendu public aujourd'hui et a
remis aux autorités
et disons le tout de suite c'est un
petit peu la montagne qui accouche d'une
souris
peu de surprises la presse avait déjà
presque tous sortis oui il y a eu délit
d'initié dit la cob mais pour l'instant
on ne sait pas qui a fraudé
alors avant de voir en détail les
conclusions de ce rapport revoyons cette
journée décisive de la sphère pechiney
et les allées et venues de ses
principaux acteurs dominic thiem
ponctuelles la réunion des cinq membres
du collège de la commission des
opérations de bourse devait commencer à
9 heures ce matin jean farges le
président de la cob arrive juste à
l'heure c'est son jour dans quelques
minutes jean farges ses collaborateurs
prendront connaissance du rapport du
service d'inspection dirigée par jean
pierre michaud deux heures de débat deux
heures d'étude du rapport et deux heures
de suspense pour les différents acteurs
du dossier
apparemment pourtant ils sont sereins
ceux qui font les gros titres de la
sphère pechiney ainsi alain boublil
est ce que j'attendais du rap roda cob
il esquisse un sourire mais l'ancien
directeur de cabinet de pierre bérégovoy
ne fait aucun commentaire même heure
même comportement pour roger patrice
pelât
et là encore pour le proche de françois
mitterrand c'est le mutisme
samir traboulsi pour sa part reste
invisible ce matin quant à max théret
lui il est introuvable
je suis terrée n'est pas la fin de
matinée retour à la cob avec lecture et
distribution du communiqué de la
commission à matignon au même moment le
conseil des ministres s'achève pierre
bérégovoy et michel rocard se sont
attardés ils sont les derniers à quitter
la salle du conseil
tout le monde attend la diffusion du
rapport pour le club et c'est la foire
d'empoigné à 14h30 au ministère des
finances
le rapport de la cob vient d'être rendu
public
première décision de la cob
le dossier sera transmis à la justice il
y a donc bien eu délit d'initié
la justice sera chargée elle même de
trouver les coupables d'ailleurs le
président de la cob n'a pas hésité à
dire qu'il n'avait pas tout trouvé il y
a quand même un certain nombre
d'éclaircissements dans ce rapport
françoise joly kristoff nor paix il y a
bien eu délit d'initié c'est la
conclusion de ses 47 pages signé pour la
cob par l'ancien juge michaud au menu de
ce rapport deux chapitres très attendu
l'invs recense tous les acheteurs des
actions litigieuses l'autre analyse les
arguments des acquéreurs français 228
1770 actions sont achetés à wall street
du 14 au 18 novembre soit trois jours
avant la noce officielle du contrat
pechiney american can premières
révélations du rapport le plus gros
acquéreur est américain c'est la firme
drexel burnham lambert
mais selon nos informations il
semblerait que cette opération soit sans
tache
rien de nouveau en revanche du côté de
la suisse et du luxembourg
les acheteurs répertoriés sont déjà
connus côté français roger patrice pelât
bien acheté dix mille actions sur les
conseils de max théret max théret
véritable vedette de ce rapport avec sa
société
la scpp la compagnie parisienne de
placement dix pages lui sont consacrés
avec une conclusion les ordres de la
compagnie sont éminemment suspect et la
cob démonte un les arguments avancés par
max
ray multiples contradictions
explications évolutive affirmations
erronées
voici les termes utilisés par la cob
dans son rapport
un exemple max théret a toujours dit
s'être appuyé sur cette lettre pour ses
achats d'actions
ces forêts pour la cob l'arctique et
ville d'information et avec la grève des
postes
max théret n'a pas pu recevoir ce
courrier à temps enfin dans le rapport
pratiquement pas un mot sur un homme
samir traboulsi qui ce soir se déclare
serein j'étais très heureux d'avoir
coopéré avec la cob et j'espère que
toute manifestation de la vérité
comme j'ai les maintes fois des ne
pourra que me servir mes intérêts en
conclusion la cob l intime conviction
qu'il y a bien eu délit d'initié et
plusieurs fuites
mais là s'arrête son enquête nous
n'avons pas trouvé
loin de là il faut mettre maintenant
pour aller plus avant des moyens pour la
justice
missions administratives à présent c'est
donc à la justice de s'emparer du
dossier les acheteurs les hommes de
cabinet les intermédiaires ceux des
charges financières les vendeurs la
plupart devraient être entendus par le
juge d'instruction
un juge qu'il reste à désigner côté
ministère public c'est le procureur de
paris pierre bézard qui est chargé de la
faire
c'est un expert du délit d'initié très
bientôt une information judiciaire sera
ouverte
les coupables encourent de 2 mois à deux
ans de prison et une amende pouvant
atteindre 4 fois le bénéfice réalisé
voilà donc pour le contenu de ce rapport
de la cob avec nous le ministre de
l'économie des finances pierre bérégovoy
bonsoir monsieur bérégovoy reçoit alors
vous aviez dit récemment encore toute la
vérité sera faite sur cette affaire les
coupables seront désignés j'imagine que
ce soit vous êtes un peu déçu je ne suis
pas déçu et je pense qu'il faut que la
sphère suive son cours
ce que j'avais dit aux français c'est
que le dossier ne serait pas étouffer la
cob a fait un rapport dans de bonnes
conditions avec les moyens dont elle
dispose
elle constate un délit d'initié elle
saisit la justice à la justice
maintenant de d'accomplir sa mission
faire être très très long avec
l'adjectif je ne peux pas savoir si ce
sera long ce qui m'importe c'est que la
vérité soit connue que rien ne soit
cacher aux français la cob déjà fait un
excellent travail
c'est elle qui a inventorié ce qui s'est
passé sur le marché américain
monsieur farges a envoyé monsieur
michaud chef du service des enquêtes de
la cob aux états unis des contacts ont
été pris sur place avec les suisses des
contacts ont été établis avec la place
de londres avait plus que son bourg et à
partir de là vous remarqué que la la cob
a identifié 228 1770 action triangle qui
ont été achetés et vendus dans la
semaine décisive
voilà un point d'acquis pour le reste il
appartient maintenant à la justice de
mener son action elle dispose de moyens
qui permettront je l'espère
de connaître la vérité en tout cas je ne
fais remarquer que c'est un fait sans
précédent
c'est un fait sans précédent
un fait sans précédent sur la place de
paris dès que j'ai été saisi par la cob
d'une enquête demandée par la secte il
faut bien se rappeler que ces achats
d'actions ont lieu sur le marché
américain puisqu'il s'agit d'entreprises
américaines
j'ai tout de suite demandé que la com
agissent avec célérité et fasse son
enquête
l'enquète abouti à des conclusions qui
sont claires et romani en guise de santé
sur la justice on compte tous un but si
ce monsieur me c'est justement depuis
1983 la cob a transmis à la justice
douze dossiers et pour l'instant aucun
la boutique par exemple le dossier eut
digestion qui est cité dans l'eau dans
ce rapport de la coop a été transmis
déjà en novembre 83 il n'y a rien à
lorsque la salle a l'air de plus vite ce
que je peux vous dire c'est que la cob a
bien fait son travail
je souhaite d'ailleurs que l'on puisse
renforcer ses pouvoirs
car il est très important pour moi
chargé de l'économie et des finances de
ce pays que la place financière de paris
soit transparente et moraliser sur le
dossier pechiney comme sur toutes les
autres affaires qui alimente les
conversations
elle revenait à partir du moment où la
cob a fait son enquête elle transmet à
la justice
je n'ai pas à m'en mêler c'est à la
justice de faire son travail et je
connais assez les juges de notre pays
pour savoir quand toute indépendance
ils mèneront la faire à son terme
revenons à ce dossier pechiney le super
ego voit alors le rapport ne désigne pas
nommément de coupables est ce que vous
vous en savez plus non je n'en sais pas
plus
je constate que la cob indiquent dans un
rapport que vous connaissez que
plusieurs personnes dit elle on peut
penser que plusieurs personnes ont donné
des informations d'initiés et permis
ainsi la réalisation d'opérations
irrégulière sur gordon anglais on dit
qu'il est une conviction intime est ce
que vous auriez eu une vous je n'en ai
pas il en a pas parlé en monsieur
grandbois n'en a pas parlé il l'a
déclaré à lui de dire à ceux qui vont
pour la charge de l'anc est ce qu'il
pense et ce qu'il sait moi je constate
simplement qu'aujourd'hui la cop10 qu'il
n'y a pas d'éléments décisifs permettant
de l'identification de ceux qui ont
donné l'information il va y en avoir
alors c'est à la justice de faire son
métier
ce n'est pas à moi n'est ce pas je n'ai
pas amené l'enquète il faut pas qu'il y
ait de confusion entre le pouvoir
exécutif et le pouvoir judiciaire
papus qu'il devait y en avoir entre la
cob et le ministre des finances
moi j'ai demandé à la cob bien monsieur
farges 4ème de caractère à l'expérience
d'aller jusqu'au bout des investigations
il y a été rapidement
rapidement il faut le constater parce
que lorsque vous observez ce qui se
passe sur les places internationales
ça ne va pas toujours aussi vite
maintenant la justice est saisie bien
monsieur grégoire faire son travail ça
nous l'avons angle ça nous l'avons vu du
cnt prenons le point par point par
exemple monsieur boublil vous avez vu ce
que la cob andy a votre avis il est lavé
de tout soupçon mais je ne dirais pas
cela
je considère qu'aujourd'hui toutes les
personnes citées doivent bénéficier de
la présomption d'innocence
on n'a pas le droit de citer un nom plus
qu'un autre ce que je constate ces
cas-là boublil a toujours dit qu'il
n'était pas responsable
il m'a remis sa démission pour défendre
son honneur regretté que je les relis z
line ans je lui fais confiance pour
défendre son honneur vous avez vu les
attaques dont ils étaient l'objet
moi je ne dispose pas d'information me
permettant d'en dire plus
il faut que l'on s'habitue permettez-moi
de le dire à dans une société de droit à
ce que la justice se prononce sur la
base de faits précis et non pas sur la
base d'insinuations regretter de l'avoir
repris comme directeur de cabinet quand
ils disent non il a fait du bon travail
autour de moi il a été mêlé à cette
affaire qui était bonne pour la france
l'achat de triangle par péchiney des
informations ont circulé sur lui et sur
beaucoup d'autres je souhaite que la
lumière soit faite
je fais confiance à alain boublil pour
s'exprimer comme il l'entendra
dernier point mais je ne pouvais pas
à venir moi je trouve normal je l' ai
déjà dit que à côté
ils ont des procédures d'enquêtés
administratives la presse cherche en
savoir plus vous n'avez jamais entendu
contester le rôle de la presse
mais moi je ne peux pas me substituer à
la justice
et je ne le ferai pas parce que j'estime
que nous sommes dans une société de
droit
ce que je peux simplement dire aux
français comme je leur avais déjà
annoncé cette affaire ne sera pas
étouffée je souhaite la vérité je ne
souhaite pas simplement pour ceux qui
aujourd'hui vont alors non si vous êtes
bien monsieur je la souhaite allier de
faire un jeu c'est les choses vite parce
que si c'est donc je la souhaite pas les
français ne sont pas en effet je
souhaite que cela aille vite mais je
souhaite aussi que cela soit fait
suivant des procédures normales mais ce
que je souhaite c'est que la vérité soit
établie afin que la place financière de
paris devienne ce cas doit être un
endroit où l'argent s'investit dans
l'intérêt de notre économie et non pas
un endroit où des profits que je juge
scandaleux sont réalisés dont j'entends
être
permettez-moi de le dire avait choqué
par monsieur restera comme le monsieur
terré je trouve anormal que l'on fasse
des coupes bourse
il s'agit de savoir s'ils l'ont fait à
partir d'informations ou s'ils l'ont
fait spontanément à eux de le dire
à eux de le dire mais je répète un point
très important
j'entends être changeant être avec la
confiance du président de république et
du premier ministre
j'entends être le ministre qui
moralisera la place de paris et assurera
la transparence des opérations
financières
pechiney société générale privatisation
mais l'actionnement la coop pour
l'instant n'a pas décidé d'ouvrir deux
dossiers la cob a à ma demande a procédé
à des investigations
si elle estime qu'elle doit aller plus
loin elle ira plus loin fouroux et large
de 1
je veux je veux que la transparence soit
assurée monsieur ferons a dit en effet
des choses
il n'a pas apporté à ma connaissance ni
à celle de la cob des éléments de que
disons qui permettait
d'en savoir plus mais je répète si la
cob a le moindre élément permettant en
effet de donner les informations utiles
l'opinion moi je suis pour
c'est vous comprenez bien mon objectif
je trouve qu'il est normal que l'argent
s'investissent à la bourse
je trouve anormal les profits scandaleux
je trouve qu'il n'est pas juste dans une
société qu'il y en ait qui fasse
beaucoup de sacrifices pour que notre
économie marche bien et qui en est
d'autres qui s'enrichissent sans cause
mais revoilà suggérez vous voir vous
dire merci à vous a eu le temps de le
dire et je compte beaucoup sur l'opinion
pour me soutenir dans cette affaire il
est très important que le pignon et
conscience que le gouvernement veut la
vérité est que le gouvernement veut la
salubrité
il faudra que la justice aille vite donc
merci monsieur bérigaud vois mes côtés
les acteurs de la sphère fesci n'est peu
de réaction ce soir tous pour l'instant
consultent leurs avocats premier
politique à réagir andré lajoinie pour
le parti communiste le rapport de la cob
ne fait pas beaucoup de clarté sur les
affaires qui ont permis à des spectacles
des spéculateurs de rafler des milliards
en profitant de leurs relations
privilégiées c'est ce que disait
monsieur lajoinie mais bien sûr c'est à
droite que les réactions étaient les
plus attendus écoutez
ainsi la montagne accouche d'une souris
est la conclusion du rapport de la cob
s'est finalement que le gouvernement a
perdu six semaines dans la recherche de
la vérité
il aurait pu depuis six semaines saisir
la justice qui aurait pris les mesures
conservatoires nécessaires et notamment
le blocage des comptes bancaires des
intéressés il aurait pu depuis six
semaines ouvrir une enquête
administrative pour savoir d'où venait
la fuite dans l'administration française
comme jean gandois le laissait entendre
dans la presse hier enfin il aurait pu
depuis six semaines saisir les autorités
helvétiques comme cela n'a été fait bien
tardivement qui hier le gouvernement a
fait bien peu pour rechercher la vérité
premièrement il apparaît qu'il y ait
délit dj c'est ce que nous avions
aujourd'hui
deuxièmement il apparaît que des
personnes proches du pouvoir ont été à
l'origine des fuites et donc les fuites
sont bien ce concert la corde n'a pas
identifié les auteurs elle parle de
plusieurs auteurs il appartiendra à la
justice d'aller plus avant dans une
animation
voilà pour les affaires ajoute tout de
même que ce matin le conseil des
ministres a adopté un projet de loi sur
le dénoyage des sociétés privatisées ces
techniques mais il s'agit de rendre leur
liberté aux actionnaires stables de ces
sociétés
fin du feuilleton ce soir le reste de
l'actualité
à commencer par la sécheresse est un
hiver exceptionnel que nous vivons vous
l'avez tous constaté mais c'est vraiment
exceptionnel deux exemples les premiers
feux de forêt ont eu lieu sur la côte
d'azur et oui c'est vous dire qu'il y
fait chaud
deuxième exemple l'île de molène en
bretagne obligé d'être ravitaillés en
eau potable en janvier on croit rêver
plus inattendu la sécheresse et le temps
calme entraîne une très forte pollution
en europe particulièrement en italie car
cet hiver exceptionnel sévit en effet
sur toute l'europe
reportage à milan marcel trillât pour
une fois qu'il fait beau à milan dans
cette ville perpétuellement noyé dans le
crachin il n'a pas plu depuis des
semaines les couches d'air froid et sec
qui stagne au dessus de la plaine
milanaise bloc l'air chaud et les gaz de
la ville la plus active
dany une sorte de gigantesque cocotte
minute à l'intérieur des taux de dioxyde
d'azoté et d'anhydride sulfureux qui bat
tous les records en temps normal déjà la
pollution à milan est deux fois plus
importante qu'à paris trois fois plus
qu'à tokyo
les chiffres rendus publics depuis des
mois par l'om est ce sans qu'aucune
mesure concrète n'ait été prise alors
vendredi dernier le maire socialiste
perd son calme et appelle les
automobilistes à renoncer à pénétrer
dans la ville sauf en cas d'extrême
nécessité
une supplique qui s'adressait
particulièrement aux 400 milles qui
viennent chaque jour des villes voisines
travailler à milan résultat lundi matin
ça n'a pas diminué
non j'ai même l'impression qu'il y en a
encore plus les gens continuent à
prendre la voiture et l'appel du maire
il s'en fiche complètement
c'est facile pour quelqu'un qui habite à
milan moi je viendrai chien comment je
peux faire qu'est-ce que j'en fais de ma
voiture
cinquante mille voitures de plus chaque
année
on commence à se demander à minan s'il
était bien raisonnable de supprimer les
tramways et de remplacer les trolleybus
par des bus à moteur diesel hyper
polluants
autre idée de génie l'installation en
plein centre-ville des bureaux de la
douane qui attire chaque jour dix mille
semi remorques internationaux milan
n'est pas la seule
a pas l'air à naples à florence aaron
cela commence aussi à sentir le souffre
et au carnaval de venise cette année
c'est ce genre de masque qui fait fureur
l' affaire des espions de la fusée
ariane
et bien ce n'étaient pas des espions le
non lieu a été prononcé pierre vernier
le polytechnicien de l'insee entonna
manole et jean michel ory ont été lavés
de tout soupçon il l'espionnaient pas
pour l'union soviétique pour antenne 2
ils ont enfin accepté de parler
agnès poirier patrick voir le
soulagement pierre verdy respire enfin
19 mars 87 après 30 heures
d'interrogatoire à bout de nerfs pierre
verdy avoue policy la dst qu'il est bien
un espion il se rétracte immédiatement
mais c'est trop tard la sphère des
espions d'ariane commence nous avons été
choisis pour monter une affaire pour
monter une affaire qui n'existait pas en
fait
alors pourquoi j'ai été choisi parce que
j'avais épousé une soviétique parce que
j'étais allé plusieurs fois en union
soviétique
parce que j'avais un travail que
certains considéraient comme important
une épouse soviétique ludmila varig in
pour l'ingénieur polytechnicienne
l'insee mais aussi une ancienne
maîtresse rummel président de
l'association culturelle roumanie
normandie et poète à ses heures elle est
surveillée depuis longtemps par la dst
et oui on venait toujours demandé
on avait des plus tôt des contacts
ponctuelles pour savoir ce que nous
avions fait si nous avons sorti en même
temps si nous voyons des gens bizarres
mais parmi les anciennes connaissances
de nina noto jean michel ory ce
dessinateur industriel intérimaire a
travaillé pour la sep
là où sont mises au point les moteurs
d'ariane plus aucun doute pour la dst il
s'agit bien d'un réseau d'espions mais
le roman d'espionnage s'est terminé cet
après midi non lieu pour insuffisance de
preuves en afghanistan le retrait
soviétique s'accélère l'armée rouge sera
parti le 15 février tout kaboul tremble
dans la tente de cette libération qui ne
fera pas plaisir à tout le monde
kaboul en état de siège résultat toutes
les ambassades ferme
nous vous l'avons dit la france est déjà
parti à la fin de la semaine il ne
restera plus qu'une trentaine de
diplomates
michel mots comptés il devait avoir
quitté kaboul le 15 février
mais les soviétiques ont aujourd'hui
plus d'une semaine d'avant ce un départ
pour le moins précipitée
un véritable pont aérien a été mis en
place sur l'aéroport de kaboul
direction l'union soviétique après neuf
ans de guerre
ici on ne laisse rien l'armée rouge
semble fuir son vietnam
quatorze ans après les états unis
sur cette route de salang la seule voie
d'accès vers l'union soviétique qui ne
soit pas encore aux mains des
moudjahidine vingt mille hommes de
l'armée rouge doivent encore d'ici
vendredi passé
kaboul prend chaque jour davantage les
allures d'une capitale assiégée
les réserves d'eau de la ville sont
totalement épuisé plus d'essence plus de
nourriture
le bruit des canons des moudjahidine se
rapproche sans cesse et comme pour
augmenter les difficultés il n'a pas
fait aussi froid ici depuis 15 ans les
enfants sont bien sûr les premiers
touchés malnutrition n'est kaboul n'a
plus de les infections kaboul n'a plus
de médicaments
ici on attend maintenant après neuf ans
de guerre la dernière des batailles
une bataille qui pourrait bien être pour
tous les kaboulis la plus sanglante de
toute l étonnement d'avions au-dessus de
la mer des caraïbes un avion colombien
avec 116 personnes à bord des tournées
vers le costa rica pour l'instant on
ignore les exigences des pirates de
l'air je vous propose maintenant de voir
d'autres informations internationales à
commencer par l'ouverture aux états unis
du procès de oliver north l'homme clé de
l'irangate au lit pour les intimes
écoutons claire chazal c'est l'ancien
leader des réfugiés soviétique anatoli
sharansky qui va être l'avocat d'israël
auprès des nations unies
moshe arens ministre israélien des
affaires étrangères vient en effet de
choisir le dissident soviétique comme
ambassadeurs de l'état hébreu dans une
enceinte internationale où cet état a
souvent été critiqué mathématiciens de
41 en anatolie sharansky avaient été
libérés des camps soviétiques en février
86 où il avait été emprisonné pour
espionnage au profit des états unis
il s'est ensuite longuement battu pour
que les juifs soviétiques fils d'émigrés
le procès de l'un des principaux acteurs
de la reine gates lieutenant colonel
oliver knowles a commencé ce matin
membre du conseil national de sécurité
nord avait profité des bénéfices tirés
des ventes d'armes à l'iran
en 1985 pour aider les contrats anti
sandiniste du nicaragua mais révélé à
l'automne 86 la sphère avait déjà fait
l'objet de très nombreuses auditions
devant le congrès que toute l'amérique
avait pu suivre à la télévision
le procès de nantes risque donc de se
dérouler maintenant dans une relative
indifférence
et cela d'autant que les deux principaux
chefs d'accusation notamment celui
d'avoir conspiré pour tromper le
gouvernement ont été abandonnées
c'est le ministre français de
l'industrie roger fauroux qui a signé
aujourd'hui à moscou un nouvel accord de
coopération nucléaire franco soviétique
l'accord concerne les applications
pacifiques de l'énergie nucléaire et
touche pour la première fois des aspects
industriels et commerciaux
le commissariat à l'énergie atomique et
son homologue soviétique fabriqueront
ainsi en commun des réacteurs à eau sous
pression de nouvelle génération en
france le dernier grand discours d'andré
bergeron c'était ce matin à vincennes à
l'ouverture du congrès de force ouvrière
devant 5000 délégués henri bergeron très
ému a réaffirmé sa foi dans le
syndicalisme et dans l'avenir de force
ouvrière véronique auger d'aider la sttr
signe des autographes sur son rapport
d'activité andré lancien quitte son
syndicat des sanglots dans la voix
en 1936 je vendais des timbres pour la
république espagnole
je croyais à la nécessité du combat pour
la justice sociale
je croyais au plus profond de moi même
au syndicalisme et bien 52 ans après j'y
crois comme au premier jour
et si je pouvais recommencer je
commencerai eu pour s'ouvrir le stade i
dans la salle et surtout pincement au
coeur face à la succession difficile
contrairement à l'habitude le secrétaire
général n'a pas désigné son successeur
entre les deux candidats c'est la guerre
marc blondel rassembler plus
contestataire claude pouces et plus
conservateurs pour prévenir toute envie
de scission andré bergeron a rappelé que
lui pendant 25 ans de règne n'exclut
personne
une gageure que même les lombaires a
raté pour moi il n'y a jamais eu de
moutons noirs
je souhaite qu'il en soit de même dans
l'avenir son testament tient en quelques
mots
d'abord la tolérance fo n'aura pas trop
de mal à s'y faire
ensuite pas de compromission avec le
gouvernement et le patronat
un objectif qui lui sera beaucoup plus
difficile à tenir
la mort d'un prince passionnés ski
alphonse de bourbon est mort sur la
piste et pas n'importe laquelle sur la
piste des championnats du monde de
descente dans le colorado une mort
stupide pour le prétendant au trône de
france cousin du roi d'espagne et c'est
tout le milieu royalistes qui s'émeut
emmanuel vanier le prince alphonse de
bourbon lors de l'une de ses dernières
apparitions publiques en france c'était
en octobre dernier à la basilique royale
de saint denis
ils assistaient à une messe à la mémoire
de marie antoinette c'est ici aux
etats-unis que le prince a trouvé la
mort hier
excellent skieur plusieurs fois champion
universitaire il a voulu faire une
dernière descente avec ses amis au bas
de la piste des ouvriers installent est
une banderole le prince a heurté ce
câble grièvement blessé au cou il a
succombé peu de temps après alphonse de
bourbon aîné des capétiens cousin du roi
juan carlos avait 52 ans duc d'anjou et
de cadix il était l'un des prétendants
au trône de france des titres que son
cousin henri d'orléans tentes et tout
récemment de lui interdire de porter
mais le tribunal le débouter en 1972
alphonse de bourbon épouse et la petite
fille de franco deux enfants naissaient
mais la famille allait être marquée par
un drame
en 1984 le fils aîné l'héritier du titre
trouvé la mort dans un accident de
voiture
aujourd'hui c'est donc le prince louis
alphonse âgée de 14 ans qui devient le
nouveau chef de la maison des bourbons
l'aîné de tous les capétiens et pas de
championnats du monde de ski ce soir les
cours sont en train de s'entraîner pour
la descente justement en football en
revanche sélections pour deux matches
amicaux contre l'eire l'irlande et
arsenal c'est une équipe anglaise
michel platini a fait connaître sa liste
retour surprise dans l'es16 de baptiste
on est plus attendu
un retour plus attendue de josé touré
confirmation en revanche de laurent
blanc et de christian pérez et puis il
ya trois nouveaux aussi sonore de monaco
sylvestre de sochaux et du rang de
toulouse arrestation et inculpation ce
week-end de l'arsène lupin des années 80
il s'appelle éric huard
il a 24 ans il était recherché depuis de
nombreux mois changement d'identité
énorme coup de bluff au total il aurait
empêché empoché pardon plus d'un
milliard de francs and gas gorgé a couru
sur ses traces
mieux qu'un gagne-pain c'était une
passion irrésistible
eric qu on ne savait caisse croquer
accueilli jeudi dernier dans ce petit
hôtel du 9e arrondissement
on ne veut plus ici se souvenir de ce
jeune comte d'aurillac émules d'un
ampleman autrement plus célèbres le faut
et on s'y adonnent très jeune bachelier
il se distingue dans l'escroquerie aux
cartes bleues avec l'âge lui vient le
goût du luxe en juillet 88 sous le nom
de meneghetti il se fait passer pour un
inspecteur d'un service du ministère des
finances auprès d'une fonderie et fait
main basse sur trois lingots d'or valeur
300 mille francs
voici 10 en novembre chez des bijoutiers
du sentier sous le nom de bouvier ils
achètent ici pour 1 million 250 mille
francs de diamant ils seront revendus à
anvers en belgique pour 900 mille francs
à quelques rues de là encore des bijoux
et 25 faux chèques au nom de chassaing
dernière victime le times selon ses
aveux l'escroc se serait présenté au
quotidien britannique sous le nom de
dunoyer directeur du comité pour les
fêtes du bicentenaire
il aurait obtenu une commission de 4 150
mille francs pour un numéro spécial
l'escroc était aux dernières nouvelles
conseiller européen de la cee hugo a été
arrêté en possession de 22 mille dollars
et 18 mille francs il est ce soir sous
les verrous et risque cinq ans de prison
fin du journal la météo tout de suite
elle fera toujours fraîche avec laurent
cabrol vers 23h30
henri sannier pour la dernière édition
du journal et n'oubliez pas bien sur
télématin 6h45 dans télématin dans les 4
vérités à 7h45
invité de gérard morin jean pierre
brunet qui est le vice-président de
drexel burnham lambert c'est une banque
très impliquées d'après la cob dans la
sphère pechiney voilà à demain 20h
excellente soirée sur antenne 2
pour être bien pour être au mieux pour
aller plus loin
nous depuis le
fillon
de belles
office
c'est notre temps
m
ce thème gillett contours plus est cette
enquête une brasserie aps la perfection
au masculin
ce qui s'est gâché
battus à gaza
quant à thomas
soit 1 1% monsieur l'anticyclone et est
toujours là toujours aussi puissant
toujours aussi présent mais il a dû
changer de position alors ce changement
de position provoque quoi bien provoque
des flux de sud et un brassage
d'atmosphère l'air c'est vrai brasse du
vent vous allez voir que grâce à ce
brassage d'autres mosphere viennent nous
aurons des débrouillards un peu moins
épais un peu moins dense la voici la
carte du ciel pour la mi journée de
demain
les brouillards sont bien sûr présents
au petit matin mais ils seront moins
nombreux et à la mi-journée également
moins nombreux alors sur le nord le
nord-est la lorraine l'alsace la
bourgogne le jura et la région lyonnaise
ces brouillards seront têtu mais s'ils
resteront encore demain là on ne peut
pas s'empêcher d'en s'en échapper en
revanche sur la bretagne la normandie la
région parisienne le centre les pays de
l' le poitou et les charentes où la
charente charente-maritime charente où
toutes ses régions eh bien là les
éclaircies seront spontanée est beaucoup
plus fréquente qu'aujourd'hui partout
ailleurs le grand soleil donc sur une
grande moitié sud de la france
un soleil très généreux les températures
demain matin elle remonte un pitch net
on monte un petit peu quand même
regarder -3 degrés à grenoble +3 à brest
et bastia sika biarritz d'ailleurs les
3b d'accord et puis l'après-midi le 0 2
à 1 degrés à mulhouse 10 degrés à rennes
ainsi qu'à nantes ici même en passant
par 15 degrés en allant jusqu'à 15
degrés à cannes et en passant par 9
degrés par exemple ici à clermont
ferrand
alors j'en profite pour vous dire qu'il
fera plus trois ans tous trois et plus 7
degrés en montagne et cette température
de montagne par exemple il sera 2 demain
+5° dans une station qui l'appelaient
les arcs dans en tarentaise comme à la
plagne comme à tignes et c'est cela nous
amène tout naturellement vous parlez des
hauteurs de neige vous êtes nombreux à
vous lire si on va la neige à la fin de
la semaine parce que les premières
vacances sont là allez voici ces
hauteurs de neige relevés au sommet des
pistes je dis bien ce sont donc des
hauteurs maximales si nous pouvions les
voir ce serait parfait mais voici cent
des hauteurs maximales alors dont 40 à
50 cm dans les alpes du nord c'est pas
grand chose mais enfin c'est toujours ça
dans l'isère également 20 cm dans les
hautes-alpes un centimètre d'azap du sud
toujours au sommet des pistes insiste
bien voyez que vraiment bon il ya un
petit peu de neige mais ça n'est pas ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas encore ça y est
je peux quand même vous confirmer dans
les cinq-six jours qui viennent toujours
pas de plus et toujours pas de neige à
l'horizon alors un petit clin d'oeil
maintenant hier soir je vous parlais de
l'alaska bien nous risquons nous restons
en alaska
voici encore des images qu'ils viennent
de là-bas la situation s'améliore il
faisait moins 78 degrés et bien ça y est
maintenant ça se réchauffe la situation
les températures sont plus clémentes les
thermomètres a marqué aujourd'hui moins
46 degrés la vie reprend son cours bien
sûr le trafic aérien demeure perturbé
mais ce petit réchauffement justifie
vous en conviendrez vous allez le voir
que l'on se met à l'aise regardez ces
forçats de la bronzette ont choisi
d'enlever le haut par - 44 degrés ces
jeunes gens ont organisé une manif qui a
jeté un froid
ils sont torse nu 1 - 44 degrés là bas
en alaska près de traits de fairbanks
exactement demain et nous fêterons les
zelda avec un soleil qui va se coucher à
17h47 tous et à tous une bonne soirée et
puis demain matin à 6h45 ce sera josé
dans la puce
agf partenaires olympiques
futur andros toute la saveur de la
nature
je
bonsoir c'est donc ce rapport de 47
pages qui fait la une de l'actualité
comme on pouvait s'y attendre ce rapport
de la cob sur la sphère que sheen ne
comporte aucune véritable révélation
très concrètement disons que la
commission des opérations de bourse est
convaincu de l'existence de délit
d'initié et qu'elle a transmis le
dossier que voici est la justice éric
perrin jamais rapport de la cob n'avait
eu un tel succès on attendait des
révélations les 47 pages apporte
quelques informations mais surtout des
confirmations première partie
identification des acheteurs des 228
1770 action litigieuse celles acquises
entre le 14 et le 18 novembre
le plus important est américain il
s'agit de la firme drexel burnham
lambert
côté suisse la cob ne fait que confirmer
les noms des sociétés déjà citées par la
presse depuis le début de cette affaire
le rapport passe ensuite en revue les
acteurs français roger patrice pelât a
bien acquis dix mille actions triangle
mais la cob ne remet pas en cause les
explications de celui ci c max théret
qu'il aurait conseillé
max théret la véritable vedette de ce
rapport la société qu'il dirige en
partie la scpp compagnie parisienne de
placement a bien acheté 32300 titre et
la coop de conclure les ordres de la
scpp sont éminemment suspect la
justification des achats a été constitué
à posteriori pour les besoins de la
cause
pratiquement pas un mot en revanche sur
samir traboulsi l'homme d'affaires
libanais en conclusion la commission des
opérations de bourse confiant qu'il y a
bien eu délit d'initié mais elle n'a pu
faute de preuves
identifier la ou les personnes à
l'origine de la fuite
le rapport vient d'être remis au
procureur de la république qui devrait
ouvrir une information judiciaire pour
délit d'initié
quelques réactions en bref satisfaction
au ps et au rpr qui déclarent faire
confiance à la justice
déception à l'udf qui affirme que la
montagne a accouché d'une souris
le pc estime pour sa part que le rapport
n'a pas fait beaucoup de clarté sur les
affaires enfin pierre bérégovoy qui
était ce soir l'invité du journal de 20h
sur antenne 2 entend être je cite le
ministre qui moralisera la bourse de
paris fin de citation avec 1 pour signer
voyons rapidement les autres temps forts
de l'actualité
vite points pour vos premiers jours et
si je pouvais recommencer je
recommencerai upport fous rires après 25
ans à la tête de force ouvrière dernier
discours d'andré bergeron devant les
délégués réunis en congrès national deux
hommes sont prêts à lui sucer des flots
depuis tous et marc blondel
ils seront départagés samedi dans le
vote des délégués l'affairiste fiona
d'ariane classer les trois derniers
inculte et bénéficie d'un non-lieu en 87
il avait été accusé avec quatre autres
personnes d'avoir transmis à un pays
vers des renseignements sur les moteurs
de la fusée ariane
le prince alfonso de bourbon d'espagne
ce fut à ski sur une piste du
championnat du monde dans le colorado
prétendant au trône de france dans la
branche délégitimise il était membre du
comité international de ski son fils
louis âgé de 14 ans lui succède
appel de moscou aux moudjahidines
afghans après neuf ans de guerre et
d'occupation les soviétiques sur le
retour demande aux résistants de ne pas
compliquer leur départ alors qu'on
assiste en ce moment à une escalade des
combats sur cette route reliant kaboul à
la frontière soviétique
les chiffres du jour la bourse de paris
fait une nouvelle fois grise mine
l'indicateur instantanée affiché -0 64%
en fin de journée à new york wall street
vient de fermer ses portes on en est où
jean claude renaud et bien c'est une
double au ce soir à new york henry
d'abord la hausse du dollar le billet
vert dopée par les déclarations d'alan
greenspan le patron de la réserve
fédérale qui n'exclut pas un nouveau
resserrement de sa politique monétaire
eh bien le dollar vous l'avez vu
s'envole à 6 francs 37 85 contre six
francs 32 48 heures ensuite la hausse de
wall street avec ce qu'on peut appeler
un rally de dernière minute puisque l'
indice dow jones s'envole lui à 2340 de
32 en hausse de 18 points 21 voilà les
chiffres voilà les fait plus de
commentaires tout à l'heure
effectivement à tout à l'heure savoir
c'est la chronique sciences et
techniques du mardi ce soir patrick
esther notre spécialiste nous expliquera
que l'on peut étudier de nouvelles
molécules grâce à l'ordinateur regardent
et testent le dépistage de maladies
nouveaux médicaments
voici l'ordinateur qui va aider les
chercheurs un logiciel mis au point par
la société bio structure à strasbourg
il permet de visualiser en trois
dimensions les molécules à analyser les
biochimistes vont pouvoir manipuler ces
nouvelles molécules l'ordinateur en les
comparant avec celles déjà connues et
enregistré dans sa mémoire va pouvoir
faire gagner un temps précieux
voilà d'autres précisions plus technique
tout à l'heure dans le dernier journal
aux alentours de 23h30 la tendance météo
pour demain peu moins de brouillard et
des températures matinales un peu plus
douce confirmation laurent cabrol
oui harry des vents de sud vont venir
brasse et l'atmosphère demain résultat
beaucoup moins de brouillard
tant mieux avec des températures qui
seront qui vont osciller entre 1 et 15
degrés moyenne nationale 9 degrés voici
et puis de très belles éclaircies sur le
littoral méditerranéen ainsi que dans le
sud-ouest et un soleil dominant le
soleil le voilà en montagne à tout à
l'heure
prochain rendez vous d'information aux
alentours de 23h30 23h35 en attendant
voici signer paris une émission proposée
par pierre tchernia à la fiche d
interwiew prestigieuse je ne vous en dis
pas plus mais surtout des documents
étonnants retrouvé par pierre tchernia
à l'occasion du premier anniversaire de
la vidéothèque de paris merci d'avoir
choisi antenne 2 à tout à l'heure
mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir voila que
john kelly et minnelli viennent de
rendre hommage à paris dans un extrait
de un américain à paris et nous allons
ce soir rendre hommage à paris avec ciné
paris une émission que j'ai préparé avec
dominique froissant et jean-claude
rohmer et que réalise nino menti nous
sommes à la vidéothèque de paris où j'ai
eu l'occasion avec frédéric mitterrand
de vous présenter pendant un trimestre
bonjour la télé et à la vidéothèque de
paris va fêter dans quelques jours son
premier anniversaire
la vidéothèque de paris si par hasard
vous ne savez pas elle se trouve
tenez regardez les images qui arrivent
elle se trouve au chevet de l'église
saint-eustache dans le forum des halles
vous descendez les escaliers et vous
vous trouvez dans la mémoire de paris
car il y as je crois bien cher véronique
cayla directrice de ces lieux 12 cents
heures de programme ici 200 heures de
programmes ce qui fait 3000 films
actuellement disponibles et en un an
vous avez vu passé combien de personnes
à 40000 personnes maintenant sont venus
jusqu'à jusqu'au jour d'aujourd'hui et
le public est composé de à beaucoup de
jeunes effectivement puisque nous avons
40 % d'étudiants et même 50 55 personnes
qui ont moins de 30 ans et à notre grand
étonnement d'ailleurs il ya 40 % du
public qui ne fréquente aucun autre
équipement culturel dont nous sommes
très fiers
alors tous les jours sauf le lundi
l'après midi on vient ici on s'installe
devant ses petits tableaux on appuie sur
des boutons et on demande soit des
titres plus longue connaît soit des
références par rapport à un sujet qui
vous intéresse et là il ya un robot qui
s'appelle magnus je crois c'est un robot
qui se met en route et qui va chercher
la cassette dont vous avez besoin et qui
vous l'envoie wiki qui commence au début
du
du programme que vous avez appelé est
comme ça vous pouvez regarder le
document du visuel que vous avez choisi
et bien jetons un coup d'oeil sur cette
extraordinaire robot est ce que je
voudrais savoir c'est si vous avez en
dehors des gens qui viennent voir un
film se documenter de façon générale
comme un sujet des chercheurs pointu si
je peux dire à nous avons beaucoup de
personnalités diverses bibliothèques à
une grand public qui vient pour se
distraire il ya aussi effectivement
beaucoup de personnes qui viennent
travailler puisque en fait c'est le seul
endroit où l'on peut venir consulter
l'image animée comme on consulte un lit
c'est à dire en faisant marche avant
marche arrière sur le film que l'on a
choisi de regarder ce jour là par
exemple alors par exemple il ya une
personne qui actuellement fait une thèse
sur la tour eiffel à travers le cinéma
et qui prend tous les documents dans
lequel à tour eiffel et présente s'y
arrête et puis dessine le cadre tel
qu'il a été voulu par le réalisateur ou
par le metteur en scène il fait donc une
thèse sur ce sujet alors nous allons
parler de paris et vous le verrez à la
fin de l'émission nous parlerons aussi
d'autres villes que paris pour une
raison qui viendra en son honneur
si vous faites le plaisir de rester avec
nous pour l'instant et je pense que ça
va faire plaisir à frédéric qui aime
tant les images qui bougent
voici des images sorties de la
vidéothèque et nous allons commencer par
des images qui date de 1913 qui viennent
de la cinémathèque albert kahn qui a été
qu'ils ont été tournées par les
opérateurs de ce mécène qui aimait tant
le cinéma et qui envoyait des gens se
promenaient dans le monde entier et
d'abord à paris ironique vous qui savez
tous la première image de paris c'était
quand je crois bien c'est 1896 je crois
même qu'on va la regarder tout à l'heure
elle est forte la rose et la
cinémathèque des modes de la vidéo avec
loi là tenez regardez regardez les
images doc des opérateurs d'albert kahn
ils sont sur la plate forme d'un autobus
d'un homme illustre me ravit ngala et
c'est une promenade et un travelling
arrière
un travelling arrière une bicyclette de
l'époque je voudrais signaler que plutôt
que de mettre des musiques des racques
times nous avons choisi deux
de reconstituer des bruits qui ne sont
pas exactement des bruits d'époque ne
qui donne un peu plus de réalité à
l'image la pierre c'est vous qui courent
et non absolument c'est mon cheval du
cheval discret au village
mark recchi ne sont pas n'ont pas réussi
à retrouver la salle ans de magie vous
passez les images à la bonne cadence
voilà et alors là une saynète regardez
bien ce garçon de café
il hésite entre trois choses est ce qui
va les faire pipi
est ce qui va se faire tout mené par les
cinéastes mais ce qui va les faire son
boulot il n'a pas encore très bien
décider
il envisage de satisfaire un besoin fort
naturel et puis l'appel du labeur est
trop forte
photo mh dans son café alors là nous va
si douce aux tons quelques années c'est
1920 ce sont des plans des plans du
quartier latin et nous allons maintenant
jeter un coup d'oeil sur un document que
j'ai trouvé particulièrement savoureux
ce sont des extraits d'un film que les
compagnies d'autobus avait fait pour
apprendre leur métier aux conducteurs
dit dans mon bonhomme il faudra me
boutonnet ce bouton et puis la cigarette
là que vous avez sur l'oreille gauche
il faut me l'a rangé et voilà events and
de respect du service des princes de
fumée sous peine de révocation est il
écrit sur une pancarte
et alors au travers parce que c'est ça
qui est bouleversant dans ces documents
nous allons encore avoir l'occasion d'en
parler beaucoup pendant la soirée
c'est que ces documents ont tous été
tourné dans un but précis sans savoir
que par la suite il réussir est à calmer
d'autres impatience et hélas nous avons
l'occasion à cause de ce film
documentaire pour les conducteurs
d'autobus de nous promener dans paris en
1927 28,4 et rouge
et encore plus de piétons tombola et un
angle les embouteillages aux pieds tout
puisque en août et est devenu sous vos
yeux
regardez sur le dos du receveur la
publicité ou plutôt le l'ombre des
dumistes et ces cadeaux je crois bien la
maman de véronique cayla qui veut
descendre la balade et des fabriques se
trouvent les petits enfants qui passent
ça c'est le b trocadéro gare de l'est
avec un plan subjectif l'a absolument
vous êtes le conducteur oui même là il
était là il était dans l'autobus et
regarder l'opéra
un très joli plus formidable
et hop à ta place tu as la défunte
facile et toujours un film pour les
conducteurs nation toujours le film
d'ailleurs il va s'achever dans un
instant encore une fois les bruits que
nous entendons sur des bruits que nous
avons rajouté
et voilà l'épisode émouvant il va
remplir son arrosoir d'eau pourquoi pour
donner à boire aux gros monde et
maintenant le cinéma sonore arrive 1932
la brigade spéciale
m
et
rouler la brigade moto
aux pieds
1 pour un procès verbal aucune chance
d'y goûter bon poids procès verbal
aucune chance d'y couper et superbe voix
cette extraordinaire ça c'est quelque
chose qui se perd complètement
c'est à dire ce qui est on on n'entend
plus des voix comme celle là non mais
dieu merci l'on revient tout de même
quelques une voix qui s'est rendu
célèbre tous les pays où il ya encore
quelques voix nasillarde heureusement
qu'ils maintiennent comme elles peuvent
ces souvenirs restent les imitateurs
paraît-il alors tout cela bien sûr a
commencé avec l'équipe lumière en 1895
96 et les plans des frères lumières sont
des plans magnifiques parce qu'ils sont
longs parce qu'ils sont larges parce
qu'on on sent le mouvement de la vie
observée sans rapidité sans montage
tenez voici quelques vues de paris fait
par les frères lumière
regardez la rue de rivoli
encore une fois je le répète les sondés
sont que nous avons ajouté
pour donner un peu plus vérité à tout
cela il ya un arroseur au premier rang
la première d'être arrosé d'ailleurs
alors ça c'est la mi-carême de 1899 et
l'apparition d'une chose stupéfiante
pour moi qui suis pas collectionneur un
tramway refaire la terre et est un
monsieur qui s'acharnent bout rien
d'autre ou très belles planches sont ce
sont 4 vous 4 échelle de pompiers qui
rentre à la caserne et en 1972 le
docteur jennar confident de la famille
lumière et grand collectionneur
d'appareils de cinéma avec l'aide du
professeur vivier a pris un vieux
cinématographe lumière pour retourner
les mêmes lieux et vous allez les voir
nos amis de la cinémathèque les ont
complété il ya quelques jours avec des
vues en couleur dominante
l'impression extension un décor la
concorde en 1896 puis la concorde en
1972 tourné en noir et blanc
voilà
et voilà
par ce beau mois de janvier 80
notre dame 1896
l'année smeralda à l'intérieur
ça me lance
en plein travaux
la critique
et maintenant les images de 72 ont été
faites avec l'appareil avec un désaveu
aux mêmes